（手をすりすり）
最近…
寒くないっスカ…
こんにちは!はじめしゃちょーです
2シリーズ出ております。
ライオンさん
パンダさん
ワニさん
ばっふぁろー
バッファロー
BUFFALO
ごめん、もう1匹ライオン
トラさん
コアラ
ウサギさん
ハリネズミ
んで最後シャチがいるわけでございまーす。
どこに置こう...
とりあえずバァ↑ッファロー、バァ↑ッファローが多すぎなんだよな
これが僕が今持ってる全てです
こいつら全員ですねぇ
（吸）
僕にもワカラナイ
ナゼ(噛
なぜシャクれているのかよくわからないフィギュアが
今まで２シリーズ出てたんですけども
今回なんと
調子に乗ったのでしょうか
第３弾も来ましたー！
オメデトウゴザイマス
そろそろいいんじゃない
第３弾までくるってことはすごい人気なのかな？
なかなかガチャガチャで
こんなよくわかんないのが第３弾までくるってことは
売れてんじゃねってゆう説がありますねぇ
こいつぁちょっと　シャクレルプラネット旋風が来てる気がします
というわけでまさかの第３弾
買ってきた♡
カプセルはすごい涼しげな色なんですけど
あの僕が行ったときは！
めっちゃ余ってましたまだ
多分ねぇ　第一弾、第二弾めっちゃ売り切れてて
どこ行っても売ってなかったみたいなことが結構あったんですけど
全然まだ残ってたんで
欲しい方は第三弾ならまだ間に合う気がします
まぁちょっと第三弾まで来てちょっと飽きちゃっｔ…
とは言いませんがっ！
まぁこの子達のね、友達が増えるって考えると
とてもいいことなんじゃないかと思って
６つ買ったのでちょっと開けていこうと思います
はいというわけでちょっと開けていきましょうか
まずは１個目！
バッファロー三体かぶるのとか結構僕萎えたんで
カブリはホントに勘弁してほしいところではある
じゃー一個目開けていきます！
うわ軽っ！軽っ！
めっちゃ軽いぞ！いきますっ！
はいっ！
ﾌｪｯ!?
え？え？え？　誰誰誰
はいっ！
ﾌｧｯ!?
ﾌｪ!?
お犬さん？わんわんですね
うわぁ～！相変わらずのしゃくれ度ですね
すげぇ～わんわんはちょっと予想しなかったなぁ
今回何出るかちょっと見ていきましょうか
シャクレルプラネット３
あぁ～絶対シロクマが大当たりだ
シロクマ大当たりの～
トナカイもいる
あ！これわんわんじゃねぇオオカミさんだ
うわっ！アザラシもいるんだ
ペンギンと～
ナニコレ誰！？
オコジョっ！？
まぁ個人的にはやっぱシロクマが一番欲しいっすね
今回ちょっとアレですね
冬というか
寒い地方にいる動物たちがピックアップされてますね
まぁオオカミが出てまぁ良しとしましょう
ここからちょっとオオカミはカブって欲しくない所はありますね
じゃー次行きますっ！
うわぁ～ちょっと微妙な重さだなぁこれは
はいっ！！
ﾌｪｯ!?
へ？　ｱｯ!　おっおっおッホッホッ
セーフセーフセーフ！ はいっ！
これはアザラシですね～ｗ
うわぁ～　ダッｓ…　いや
イケメンだなぁ
正面キチィなぁ
これホントですねぇ
しゃくれてる以外は凄いリアルなんですよね
良い流れが来てる！どんどん行きましょう！
じゃー次これ行きます！　ちょっと白い
はいっ！
ｱｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ~　やった
ここでまさかのカブり！
やらかしましたわ…
オオカミ2体目です…
6種類あって6個しか買ってないんで
この時点で全種類制覇することは無くなりました
まぁ出来ればシロクマだけは当てたいところではある！
じゃー次行きます！
カブリだけはホントにやだぁ
行きますよぉ
はい…
え？え？え？え？
はいっ！
おいふざけんｎ…
可愛いですね…
ヤバいカブリが続いてます　アザラシです
ふざけんなマジ ブッ…
可愛いですね
ヤバいヤバいヤバい
今んとこ4つ開けて2種類しか出てないという
ヤバいですねちょっと先行きが不安ですね
頼む～カブりたくないんだよぉ～
行きますっ！
はいっ！！
あうーわうーわうーわ
流石に三体目は萎えるわ
アザラシ…三体目です…
おいこれどーすんだよっ！（#^ω^）
なんでだよっヽ(`Д´)ﾉ
くんなよっ(# ﾟДﾟ)
かぶったじゃねーかよっ
おーい！やめろよっ
うっ・せぇ・なっ
やめろ☆やめろ☆よ
やめろって
喧嘩すんんなっ
いや～この被りはヤバいですよ
仲間たちの冷ややかな目が印象的です
待って俺だって今どうなってんだこれ
え？待って5個開けて2種類しか出てないぞ
（ﾋﾟｰ)
あぁっ　ゴメンナサイ
これはもうラスト一個にかけるしかないですね
でもラスト一個重いんで
これでシロクマが出ればまぁ満足
取りあえずシロクマさえ出れば僕はもうセーフだと思ってるんで
ちょっと期待して開けてみようと思います
頼むっ！
出てくれっ！！
ﾊｯ!!
触り心地で何とか開けてみます…
きたきたきた…
ﾊｪ?　ﾌｪｯ!?
シロクマじゃん！
はっ！
ﾊｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!!
良かったぁ～やっと出たよぉ～
ラスト一匹シロクマやっと出ましたぁ～
可愛いです…ｗ
えっ？顎割れてね？
あっほら完全に割れてる完全に割れてる
すげぇ～やっぱりこいつが一番レアなんだな！
つぅわけで最後なんとか奇跡的に
シロクマを当てることができました！
いやぁ～良かったんですけどぉ～
6種類出ると思って6個買ったんですよ！
その結果がコレですよ！
たったの三種類っすよ！
おいまじでまｔ
（しゃくしゃく～）
（しゃく　しゃく　しゃく↑～）
誰だ！？
（あごー　あごー）
ううっ！？
（あごごごごごごごご）
（ご？）
（けつ顎ごー）しゃべった！
（おいおまえ）
はっ
（6個買って3種類しかでてないのかい？）
うん
（あごごごごごｗ）
ああっ？
（笑いすぎて顎がしゃくれてまうわー）
わ、笑うな！
（ま そんな悲しい顔スんなって）
（お前の周りにはこんなにもたくさんの顎がいる）
うん
（俺ももちろんその一人さ）
確かに
そうだよね
（全部当たんなくてもいいじゃないか！）
（俺たちと仲良くｓ）
うるせー。全種類ほしい―ー――！！
字幕製作者から一言
音割れシーン多くない？